[Music]
historians and political scientists
estimate that somewhere around 200
million people were killed by war
oppression and political conflicts
during the 20th century alone 200
million think about that
World War one 16 million killed the
Holocaust six million killed the
genocide in Rwanda over 800,000 and on
and on and on 200 million deaths in a
single supposedly enlightened century
and those numbers reflect just the
deaths that were politically motivated
on top of that think about the amount of
hatred oppression and personal violence
that occurs at a more individual level
the personal cases in which people have
been disadvantaged and harmed even in
the most open and democratic societies a
great deal of prejudice and
discrimination still exists based on
race nationality ethnicity religion
gender sexual orientation and a variety
of other group memberships most people
like to think of themselves as basically
good fair and peace-loving people but if
we're honest with ourselves most of us
will have to admit that we have disliked
and maybe even mistreated other people
because of our personal prejudices most
of us haven't engaged in horrible
atrocities but just about everybody has
discriminated against other people on
the basis of some personal bias what's
going on here why are people so prone to
draw lines between themselves and other
kinds of people and then dislike or hate
those other people treat them badly
fight with them and sometimes even kill
them
back in the 1970s a British social
psychologist named Henry Tosh fell
became interested in what leads groups
of people to develop prejudices and
conflicts against members of other
groups Tosh felt himself had direct
experience with one of the worst
manifestations of prejudice ever seen as
a Polish Jew he lost most of his family
in World War two and he spent much of
the war and prisoner of war camps but
then after the war
Taj fell moved to England he earned his
PhD in social psychology and he started
doing research on prejudice and conflict
at the time many psychologists assumed
that extreme cases of prejudice resulted
from certain personality variables that
were associated with a general tendency
to be prejudiced and dogmatic in
particular a great deal of research had
been conducted on the authoritarian
personality which among other things
involves the tendency to be highly
prejudiced but Taj fell had seen
firsthand how themeing Lee ordinary
Germans had developed extreme prejudices
against the Jews so he set out to
understand the social and psychological
processes that can lead ordinary people
to become frigid Asst taj fel believed
that the first step in prejudice and
discrimination is the simple act of
distinguishing us from them so he was
particularly interested in the processes
by which people categorize themselves
and other people into groups people seem
to have a natural tendency the people
put people into categories and after we
put them into categories we start
thinking of everybody in that category
as being pretty much the same and we
often begin to hold negative attitudes
toward them well to study how this
process happens Taj fell planned to
bring people into a psychological
laboratory and assign them to one of two
groups and he wanted to assign them to
these two groups on the basis of
criteria
that were so unimportant and so
arbitrary that people wouldn't show the
normal biases and prejudices that we see
in real world groups and then with those
artificial minimal groups as a baseline
Taj fell planned to add factors to the
situation that would lead the members of
each group to become prejudiced toward
the other group starting with groups
that were so artificial and random that
prejudiced toward the other groups who
wouldn't arise he could then study what
made people discriminate against other
groups well it was a great experimental
strategy but it didn't work and it
didn't work because Taj Ville couldn't
find a basis for assigning people into
groups that was so random and so
arbitrary that the groups did not begin
to show patterns of in-group favoritism
and out group discrimination just
putting people into two different groups
even when they were assigned to groups
in a random or arbitrary or meaningless
way was enough to get the ball rolling
imagine that you're in one of these
studies we take a group of people all of
them pretty much alike and we randomly
put them in Group A or group B there's
no real difference between the groups we
just assigned people to the two groups
at random or on the basis of some
trivial difference but once they're in
their groups people start thinking that
their group is better than the other
group and they start behaving in ways
that benefit their own group and
disadvantage the other group and people
show this in-group favoritism even if
they don't know the members of the other
group and even if they don't expect to
interact with them in the future
just being a member of a group leads
people to identify with and prefer their
own group develop negative views of the
other group and favor their own group
when dividing up rewards with these
minimal group effects as a starting
point researchers have taken on the look
what makes prejudice and conflict
between groups even worse one approach
to understanding prejudice and conflict
called realistic conflict theory
proposes that discrimination and
conflict arise when groups are in
competition for some scarce resource
so once two groups start competing
against one another whether for
important things such as jobs or land or
relatively unimportant things such as
winning a contest or a football game
prejudiced and negative behaviors
intensify one research demonstration of
this effect was a well known study
conducted by Moussa fer Sharif and his
colleagues 22 11 and 12 year old boys
were recruited for a summer camp at
robbers cave State Park in Oklahoma the
boys were all quite similar all were
white kids from middle-class Protestant
backgrounds none of the boys knew each
other before the study but once they
showed up at robbers cave park for camp
they were randomly assigned to one of
two groups the boys chose names for
their groups the Eagles and the Rattlers
and they made group t-shirts and flags
but during the first phase of the study
they didn't know that there was another
group of boys at the camp but then after
giving the boys time to get to know the
other members of their own group Sherif
arranged for the two groups to begin to
compete with each other they played
baseball tug of war other games as the
competition began the Eagles and the
Rattlers quickly became suspicious of
each other at first the boys expressed
their hostility only verbally they
taunted the members of the other group
called each other names but as time wore
on the conflict escalated the Eagles
burned the Rattlers flag so the Rattlers
retaliated by ransacking the Eagles
cabin and stealing the Eagles property
as time wore on the groups became so
aggressive toward each other that the
researchers had to keep them separated
so nobody would get hurt
when the researchers ask the boys to
rate the members of their groups they
showed extreme strong in-group
favoritism raiding their own group much
more positively than the other group now
keep in mind that these were essentially
identical groups of well-adjusted boys
who had no reason whatsoever to dislike
each other at least initially the only
reason that they started acting this way
was that they were members of two groups
that were in competition with each other
so merely seeing oneself as a member of
a group can start these processes
rolling and competition can fuel them
but why why do we jump so quickly from
being a member of a group to developing
negative reactions to other groups with
which we compete to answer that question
let's think about why people deform
groups at all belonging to a group can
offer many benefits being in a group
gives you people to help you when you
need it and allows you to cooperate with
other people on tasks that would be
impossible for one person to do alone
members of a group can pool their
resources so that everyone has more
available to them than any one person
would have by him or herself and of
course groups provide opportunities for
social interaction companionship support
but joining up with other people is
always a bit of a risk being in a group
is beneficial only if the other members
of the group cooperate and reciprocate
and treat us well it's very easy to be
taken advantage of when other people
don't do their share because of the risk
of being taken advantage of people don't
try to forge cooperative relationships
with everybody they meet you don't go to
the mall and just pick people at random
to form groups because you don't know
whether you can trust them but forming a
group allows people to obtain the
benefits of cooperative relationships
while minimizing the possible costs
because most groups enforce rules for
how the members should treat each other
that's not to say we don't get taken
advantage of by people in our groups of
course we do but it happens less within
cohesive groups than if we were working
with a group of random people who
weren't members of an identifiable group
by joining groups selectively people can
obtain the advantages of cooperating
with other people while minimizing the
risks of being taken advantage of so by
defining who's in and who's out of a
particular group root boundaries tell us
who is most likely to be cooperative and
helpful and trustworthy all other things
being equal we can usually trust the
average member of the groups to which we
belong more than we can trust and rely
on the members of other groups of course
many of the people who are not members
of our groups are perfectly nice
trustworthy people but we don't know
which ones and many people who are not
in our groups have no incentive to treat
us well or if they are members of
competing groups they may be motivated
to work against us so the safest
solution is for people to assume that
anybody who's not in their group might
not be trustworthy
voilá that single somewhat reasonable
tactic for protecting ourselves can lead
us to view other groups with suspicion
and distrust
it might how it not always be nice and
it can lead to prejudice conflict and
other bad outcomes but it does make a
certain amount of psychological sense a
central feature of the prejudice and
conflict that develops between groups
involves biases that favor members of
one's own group and discriminate against
members of other groups even in Tosh
Fell's minimal group studies in which
people were assigned to groups
arbitrarily and had never met the other
members of either group people viewed
their own group more favorably
and made decisions that benefitted their
own group it's useful to think of this
as two distinct biases a bias to favor
one's own group and a bias to be against
another group these two biases often go
together but not necessarily I might be
biased to see my group in very favorable
terms and want good things for my group
but that doesn't necessarily mean that I
view your group negatively or want bad
things to happen to your group I might
think that your group is just fine and I
wish it all the best even though I still
think that my group is better and I'm
more invested in being sure that things
go well for my group than for yours of
course I could hate your group and hope
that bad things happen to it and I might
even act in a prejudicial or antisocial
way toward people from your group but
the more general pattern is for people
to strongly favor their own group but
not necessarily wish harm on other
groups in-group favoritism affects our
behavior more than out-group derogation
and antagonism to make things worse
research shows that groups of people are
less cooperative and more competitive
than individuals are that is if we take
10 people and we measure how each of
them responds as individuals to members
of other groups they will be more
cooperative and less competitive and if
we put them together as a group to
respond to other groups social
psychologists call this the inter
individual intergroup discontinuity
effect there are many historical
examples of individual members of groups
that are in conflict who get along just
fine as individuals but when those
individuals are back in their own groups
they are prejudiced and aggressive
toward the other group there are many
stories of soldiers from warring armies
sitting down to chat and have a
cigarette or before returning to their
own sides or stories of political
leaders of opposing nations who develop
amicable and cooperative
personal relationships with each other
sometimes people who hate some other
racial or ethnic group have personal
friends who are members of that group as
individuals they get along fine but they
are prejudiced against each others group
the inter individual intergroup
discontinuity effect is an impediment to
groups getting along reasonable non
prejudiced people who can get along with
members of the other group as
individuals change somehow when they get
into their group researchers who have
studied this effect have uncovered a
number of reasons for it the first is
that people are naturally more
suspicious and afraid of groups than
they are of individual people when we
think of having a conflict with a single
person it often seems manageable but
when we think of having the same
conflict with a group of people we view
the threat as more serious so when we
get together in a group to talk about
problems with another group we construe
the situation as more threatening and
more antagonistic and maybe it is
because the other group is likely to be
more antagonistic than the individual
members of the group would be but in any
case groups are more suspicious and less
conciliatory than individuals are on top
of that as individuals most of us don't
like to think of ourselves as unfair or
greedy or competitive or prejudiced so
we usually try to treat other people
with civility and cooperation even if we
don't like them but interacting in a
group of people encourages a competitive
mindset something about being in a group
leads people to respond more
competitively and antagonistic aliy and
once people start working as a group new
norms kick in norms that encourage them
urge them to act in ways that benefit
the group which sometimes requires
working against other groups
another bias that creeps into judgments
of our own and other groups involves the
fact that we tend to think that members
of other groups are more similar to each
other than they really are one
consequence of this is the out-group
homogeneity effect the idea that people
generalize the behavior of one member of
the out group to other members of the
out group and then to the group as a
whole if I have a bias to think that the
members of your group are mostly all
alike and I see one member being
dishonest and I'm likely to conclude
both that all of the members of your
group are dishonest and in fact that you
belong to a dishonest group I don't do
that with my own group seeing that one
member of my group is dishonest doesn't
lead me to conclude that my whole group
is bad as we have seen it doesn't take
much for these in-group and out-group
biases to emerge just put people into
groups and had a little competition over
political power or economic resources or
moral wild ideals or which group is the
best at something and these patterns
start to emerge and given how little it
takes to create prejudice discrimination
and conflict it's no wonder that people
act so badly when there's something
truly important at stake when groups are
in a win lose or zero-sum relationship
all of these effects become stronger
it's no wonder that conflicts such as
the israeli-palestinian conflict seem so
intractable prejudice and conflict also
intensify when people feel that their
group is disadvantaged relative to other
groups doesn't matter much how well the
group is doing in an objective sense
when members of a group think that their
situation is worse in comparison to
other groups they experienced
dissatisfaction and frustration they're
more likely to derogate members of other
groups and they're more likely to behave
aggressively now these reactions might
be reasonable
if the advantaged successful group then
something to hold the other group down
but we see this effect even when the
more advantaged group isn't in any way
responsible for the inequality between
the groups
just feeling less powerful or in a
disadvantaged position causes people to
show more prejudice this is why it's so
important to minimize political and
economic inequalities if we want groups
in society to stop fighting with each
other but prejudice and conflict don't
necessarily require competition for
scarce resources prejudice and
discrimination are also fed by the
perception that another group doesn't
share the values the attitudes the moral
standards of one's own group so for an
exit for example groups in a society
that appear to violate basic social
values tend to be victims of prejudice
and discrimination they don't need to be
doing anything illegal or hurting other
groups just behaving in ways that go
against other people's values and
traditions can create these divisions so
many Americans are prejudiced against
gays and lesbians and against atheists
and against people who have many tattoos
and body piercings
but none of these groups directly hurts
or disadvantages anybody the prejudices
against them are due solely to the fact
that their beliefs or behaviors differ
from the mainstream so prejudices arise
not only in response to important
outcomes such as whether you took my job
or you took my land but also to symbolic
threats to things that we value other
animals will fight when something
important is at stake food territory
mates protecting offspring but human
beings are the only species that gets
into conflicts and starts wars over
ideas and values
so prejudice and conflict arise easily
and naturally when certain conditions
are met as we have seen some of those
conditions involve how people think
about their own and other groups
especially when they're competing for
resources but to understand prejudice we
should also look at what individual
people get out of being prejudiced
social psychologists suggest that
prejudice can provide desirable
psychological outcomes for some people
for example prejudice against members of
another group can make people feel
better about themselves
research shows for example that people
who feel insecure about their own
abilities and personal characteristics
judge other people more harshly that may
be why whites from lower socioeconomic
backgrounds tend to be more prejudiced
against members of minority groups than
upper-class whites our research also
shows that people who have suffered a
blow to their self-esteem are more
likely to discriminate against others
than people who just experienced a boost
to their self-esteem presumably feeling
superior to other people can help people
feel better about themselves people who
have the greatest desire to feel good
about themselves either because they're
in a low status social group or because
they have suffered a momentary setback
are more likely to put other people down
you might be thinking that everything
that I've said so far paints a pretty
bleak picture if people develop
prejudices and conflicts so easily and
these reactions are maintained by biases
of various kinds then how can we ever
get groups to get along
it seems built into the nature of the
human psyche to dislike and distrust
other groups well there's a bit of truth
to that so efforts to break down walls
between groups have to counteract
people's natural tendency to build and
defend those walls but it's not hopeless
researchers and the social sciences have
spent a great deal of effort trying to
understand help fred judas develops and
how we can overcome it the first thing
that research has shown is that simply
throwing members of opposing groups
together is not usually an effective
strategy it might seem that if we could
just get people from the two groups to
get to know each other as individuals
then they'd realize that they're just
all human after all and dropped some of
their biases but it doesn't work that
way
remember the study of the adolescent
boys at the summer camp when researchers
tried to bring the Eagles and the
Rattlers together just for some fun
activities their antagonism escalated in
these kinds of situations the groups
don't like or trust each other and
simply putting them together isn't going
to change their views of each other but
although simply bringing the groups
together to interact isn't likely to be
helpful it is possible to structure
their contact in ways that reduce
prejudice and conflict back in the 1950s
gordon allport described the conditions
under which group contact is most likely
to reduce negative feelings between
groups researchers have extended his
findings but he got the basics down
pretty well first the groups must have
equal status within the situation in
which they will have contact and
interact with each other even if the
groups differ in social status on the
outside in the situation in which they
are brought together they must have
equal status and power second the
situation must provide an opportunity
for the groups to cooperate towards some
common goal in the robbers cave study
that I described the Eagles and the
Rattlers showed a reduction in their
hostilities only after they worked
together toward common goals for example
the researchers arranged to have the
water to the camp cut off and the two
groups had to work together to find and
fix the problem
there must also be opportunities for
members of the two groups to become
personally acquainted
although mere contact is not enough once
they start working toward common goals
people need to start to see each other
as individuals with concerns interests
and problems that are similar to their
own and finally contact between the
groups is more likely to reduce
prejudice if some higher authority
supports the goal of bringing the groups
together in reducing the conflict the
higher authority could be a person such
as a group leader could be laws or
social customs that promote getting
along efforts to reduce prejudice are
more likely to succeed if they appear to
have legitimacy as we solve prejudice
and conflict arise when people
categorize themselves as members of
different groups but if seeing
themselves as members of different
groups feeds the development of
prejudice and discrimination then think
of what might happen if we can get
people to construe the group categories
differently what if people started to
see themselves as part of the same group
as having a common in group identity the
idea is that we can change the way
people categorize themselves from us
versus them to we this is the sort of
thing people are talking about when they
say that the whole world would suddenly
bond together if aliens attacked from
outer space then we're no longer
Americans and Germans and Nigerians and
Chinese and Brazilians suddenly were the
people of the earth working together as
one group and it would probably work a
good deal of research has shown that we
can reduce prejudice by getting members
of diverse groups to develop a shared
identity studies have looked at all
kinds of groups such as different ethnic
groups in a high school bankers from
different companies who have been thrown
together because of a merger the two
parts of a blended family that comes
together when parents remarry
in all cases once the members of the two
old groups started reconceptualizing
themselves as members of the same group
prejudice and conflict decline
unfortunately this doesn't stop the
process altogether when we bring two
groups together in this way by stressing
their common identity members of those
two groups will start seeing themselves
as one group but guess what now the
members of the new unified group may
start seeing themselves as different
from other groups that maybe they hadn't
thought much about before that might be
the most discouraging thing under the
right conditions we can help groups and
conflict come together but then the
process might be repeated with other
groups but understanding why divisions
between groups develop and the things
that can help bring them together is
certainly a good first step